- Cette soirée qui devaitous lee
des retrouvailles a dérapé.
- Oh! wow!
- À la surprise générale,
frapper l'humoriste Chris Rock
it de faire une blague
de mauvais goût à propos de son
épouse. Une fois retourné à saé
le présentateur, l'intimant de
ne plus parler de sa conjointe.
de théâtre, quelques
minutes plus tard, Will Smith
a remporté l'Oscar du meilleur
acteur pour son rôle dansle fil.
En pleurs, il a dit qu'il
voulait protéger les siens.
Il s'est excusé àmais pas à Chr.
(en anglais)
Son geste a provoqué
une avalanche de réactions
Plusieurs célébrités
l'ont dénoncé, entre autres,
l'humoriste Kathy Griffin
qui affirmé sur Twitter que les
craindre le prochain Will Smith
dans leur spectacles.
De son côté, l'Académie a
condamné le geste de Will Smith
d'une enquête sur l'incident.
La policngeles s'est
dite au courant de l'incident,
indiquant que l'individu
plainte pour le moment.
(applaudissements)issements)iss)
Mais parmi les beaux moments de
la soirée, il y a ces trois prin
du film français "La Famille
Bélier" qui raconte l'histoire
d'une famille de personnes
avec l'Oscar du meilleur film."e
a été le film le plus primé
des catégories techniques dont
e direction artistique,
prix remis au Québécois
PATRICE VERMETTE, Oscar de la
meilleurmeilleurmeilleurmeilleue
- Je peux même pas comprendre
de Montréal qui a ça, là...J'ha!
- Soulignons que le prix
allé à la production japonaise"e
la meilleure réalisation a été
son film "Le pouvoir du chien".
Pendant cette soirée,
il y a eu une minute de silence
pour les Ukrainiens.
Après deux ans de pandémie et
de cote d'écoute en chute libre,
s'est déroulée sous
le signe de la diversité.
Les producteurs souhaitaient
Cette 94e cérémonie passera
à l'histoire, mais peut-être
pas pour les bonnes raisons.
Radio-Canada, Montréal.